[Music]
hi there Josh here I'm a software
engineer working on Google clouds Auto
ml hello again and welcome back to
episode 2 in our series where we
introduce the exciting world of machine
learning and run through a quick demo of
our self-paced lab let's first recap if
you'd like to see a deep explanation of
machine learning you can check out you
things AI adventures episode here
machine learning artificial intelligence
these are all major buzz words in
today's cloud market but what's the
difference I like to think of them as
concentric circles
where you have AI is the broader concept
ml the algorithms to make AI work and
then deep learning is the type of ml
using multi-layered neural networks the
core activities in machine learning
include data gathering model building
training evaluation and parameter tuning
gather data is used to train the model
and evaluate its performance algorithms
iteratively learned from data and then
can make predictions on new examples tag
people inside photos viewing and buying
suggestions personalized search results
machine learning is actually behind a
lot of what we experience every day ml
is a great way to jumpstart any
application that already has many
examples of what you'd like the
algorithm to do let's take a use case
from Google to use the ok Google
functionality on your phone every day me
too well to build it they had to gather
a bunch of different ways people say ok
Google and use that to train the Emma
algorithm
the research team collects and annotates
many other spoken phrases so that the ml
can learn to process different
interactions for those of us without
training data the Google API is for
vision natural language translate and
video intelligence are already available
and they're a great place to get started
now the fun part
quick labs you can check out the link to
start the quick lab here this side
provides an introductory walkthrough on
training a tensile model both locally
and on cloud machine learning engine
next we will learn how to deploy to
Google Cloud prediction keep in mind
that this app will take about an hour to
complete here we've copied in some
training data from the census data set
validated the model locally and run a
single instance trainer using cloud ml
engine now we're ready to deployed the
model to cloud on CM le your model will
be able to make predictions and scale to
serve many concurrent requests create a
cloud ml engine model select the
exported model to use set an environment
variable for the output path deploy
version 1 of the train model this may
take a few minutes send a prediction
request to the deployed model the
response includes the predicted labels
of the example in the request here we
have the probabilities that the income
less than or equal to 50,000 or that the
income is greater than 50,000 well
that's all the time we have for today we
hope you enjoyed this episode and would
love to hear more about how you use or
would use google cloud machine learning
engine at your business that's right and
don't forget to check out our on air
webinar series quick lives and our blogs
all the links are below you can also
learn more about machine learning
through our Google cloud on-demand
courses on Coursera thanks for watching
and see you soon see ya make sure to
check out last week's episode about
cloud identity access management for
your business and don't forget to
subscribe
you